ah we're back everybody sorry for the
wait
I am so sorry why do I always have to
apologize you know what I'm not sorry
now sit back and enjoy the video
hey hey kid you want to buy a tutorial
it's only fifty dark dollars no did I
say fifty well we just went on sale
twenty twenty dark dollars no one only
one dollar please please I need this
right now
oh look at his face how could I say no
to that no excuse me sir I think I have
a dollar
is it dark yes perfect
right this way gentle gentle inners no
thanks
so I didn't have to replay the game from
last time oh god what is happening which
I'm happy about
I'm just happy to keep playing it we're
sorry we're normally puzzled guys but
we've been forced to do tutorials just
to make ends meet but the King got power
he fired everyone who replace old puzzle
makers with him rooks Oh God Lord of
puzzles be careful I also appreciate all
the tips that you guys send me on how to
attack and all that stuff I read it all
so hopefully I know how to play the game
a little better and yes it is a glows
glows hard because it's one word okay
everyone apt paisa close hard but it's a
glow shine it's one work it's one word
it's a glows hard because it glows hard
it's two different things stop making
fun of me all right what's it tutorial
orgies I'm Rallos a master asked me
about route seis this will be a lot of
dialogue to read I'm Chris master ask me
about Chris okay maybe I'll just read it
so I know but I won't have it in the
video okay I think I have a better
understanding now
that let's just keep going his son just
gave us all be nice it she be nice
oh hi why they're wearing it that's cute
all right what should we give something
here then if you like our tutorials
please throw money into it all right
throw a dollar you put a dollar in the
hole the hole became full excellent I
keep pressing shift like it gives me
something but it doesn't shop let's
check out shop hey hey welcome dreamless
dark candy dark burger amber card spooky
sword ooh oh we have 200
[Music]
amber card seems pretty good
and the hamburger yeah we're not
[Music]
okay maybe I shouldn't waste all of it
see you again or not ha ha ha ha ha ha
okay so amber card let's put it on there
we go
so that buffs everyone that's pretty
cool I think I got it right
yeah I'm sure everyone's gonna tell me
in the comments that I'm gonna know my
idiot
it's a lone doorframe but for some
reason you can't see through it great
there is sands too well flip my
flapjacks the grounds are back in town
the clowns well bad news since you last
saw me several minutes ago I've created
a brand new fighting team ready to stop
you not even the purple girl can stop me
now are you ready to be stopped stop
talking ho ho ho what is that why are
you saying that oh ho ho it's my evil
laugh scary right you sound like a baby
Santa Claus you mean like in a badass
way shut up
back it up you really think you know how
to be scary
well I hate rough man wanna be tough
guys like you really piss me yeah
face it you wouldn't never know scary
if it picked you up and bit your face up
but that's not true really then why
don't we prove it Sam's careful sans
we'll start with the part where your
face gets beat up I can't oh okay I get
it
Thank You purple girl what Thanks
it was kind of you to teach me how to be
scary with an evil laugh hey I wasn't
and now Jesus Christ what is that what
is that thing you're gonna be slashed
Merry Christmas I guess that's kind of
an improvement
okay so now we got first time for me to
prove that I know how to play this game
I'm sure it's gonna go great so what I
will first do is I'll all right you win
let's be friends ah come on
berry they got berry okay so now
remember he hits okay I [ __ ] up okay
Shh act befriend then we spare friends I
was thinking the same thing I feel like
I'm doing it all wrong god damn it
everyone's gonna be mad at me oh no guys
just give me a minute right it's my
first playthrough oh look Chris another
puzzle
oh no let's read the instructions huh
the instructions are vandalized it says
doused fools that will never figure it
out now ruining instructions that's
definitely against the rules then it
saves PS I make my own rules well that
explains that you just walk over them
one we just climb over this spike fence
because then we'd get impaled and die
cool I'll work on that and you do the
puzzle and try your best Chris okay so I
will stand here and then you should
stand here and then we'll all just work
- oh I see oh it's one of those oh okay
I must be great job Chris I think you're
on to something
hey Chris give up whenever you feel like
it it's all good all right I give up
I give up hey I did it look at that Wow
you did it great great job damn didn't
get to impair myself oh my god
oh well come on guys good job Chris
thank you thank you very cool all right
let's say let's deal with this guy the
various guys appeared oh you and Rousey
born the enemies about Suzy everyone
went on guard right okay
long live the guy who pays us so Suzy
attacks no matter what hey thieves
whispering a lovely spell so I guess one
thing I can oh they're already worn
Brown say will spare quit fighting it
was Swain stop any missus okay I
understand now I understand the game
amazing
I must be some sort of genius I know I
did that on purpose he dislikes its boss
but doesn't care enough to quit all
right convinced and then spare okay look
at that I know how to play the game
everybody let's go here oh god this is
ominous when you step into the light
you'll return to where you were before
okay so let's not do that what's the
pattern here
is there a pain oh it's simple okay Oh
God
okay let's which one is running X
I should have I should have started from
the bottom now we're here okay you
[ __ ] idiot come on come on I need I
need supportive comments stop it what
left I'm doing the thing where you
overthink everything and it all goes
wrong there we go it was really okay I'm
sorry
here we go keep playing you know I'm not
sorry screw you I don't need your
judgment Oh God why didn't you warn me
okay so good night warning everyone went
on guard they miss okay this is epic
cool alright I'll probably cut these
down okay that was epic everyone we're
in a chessboard and we got the same
puzzle well how in the world am I gonna
do that it was kind of obvious actual
brain let here Oh God the halfway point
to our castle hmm impressive so it's a
shame
you won't make it a step further because
my guys are about to smash you into
blood lots of blood splashing blood very
gross and man oh god he has a bucket
everyone stay safe
hey papa girl was that scarier why are
you asking me because you're really cool
and being terrified I wanna be as scary
as you you want to be like me yeah well
that's stupid but then your life isn't
as awful and saying you'd turn us into
blood is cool what the hell is with the
bucket no it's to put the blood in oh
[Music]
yeah I'm not supposed to make a mess
anyway thanks for your feedback
I'm really feeling scary no problem I
guess
so are you guys gonna attack us sir oh
yeah I was so excited I forgot to bring
any guys but next time it'll be the end
for hey I just been calling you guys
clowns
does your team having a facial name or
something
Oh Chris we should come up with a name
no we shouldn't then it's decided
everyone puts the name in the bucket
[Music]
yeah all right everyone
yep the bucket came in handy how about
that everyone's put in the red treats
Lopez and you can choose then you look
like you don't care Lancer labeled paper
a neat paper crumble people you take the
crumble up piece of paper you open it up
that's clearly Suzie's their name isn't
it okay and your name is I don't think
I'm allowed to say this one it's
pronounced whoa I'm not allowed to say
tier two swear words
wow you three is collective dad must be
very cool
Carrie perhaps considered a different
name Rosie
you don't have to be in our squad yeah
how about I be in the squad and you bein
fed the bag here call up my dad tell him
he has a new son once at a stick hey
what was i once that has to take a
shower every time he reads a swear word
one that has it outside okay fine we can
keep that name I just won't say ha ha me
too see ya losers it's jabber time hey
save station gotta love that save
station the fox squad shines eyes a fox
what does the Fox say that's what I'm
saying
YouTube do on a tide station bot alright
let's keep going God dad Wow
gotcha roll typically
Oh Oh God
like I think that's in woof stressful I
can't let my bros down oh god it's
another one and another one and another
one and enough I probably should have
bought one at a time okay
act and warning can't hit this wow what
an epic battle that was incredible
alright any more light puzzles there we
go we get the same all right what is
this
well DC bumming were scary but but all
in we're doing is following the king I
was on the board used to have our own
bus those and were peaceful times but
now even the boss has been reduced to
the Kings poet Pepe on no words fear not
we unlike the simple pawn men possess
full faculty over our actions I mister
society societies really everyone am far
too intelligent to ever bow down to such
a tyrant unless he asked me he's very
scary you see I feel the same way I'm
completely independent from YouTube as
long as YouTube doesn't become me nice
oh well step on my boots if it isn't the
name I'm not allowed to say your boys or
girls had better turn back while you can
non sir what is it this time I'm simply
warning you Oh something extremely
dangerous is like a head it's actually
really inconvenient inconvenience ha I
can't go home at all because I'm so
scared
what what is it what is it oh hey little
guy that that's what you're afraid of
Oh papa girl you aren't scared hey why
would I be what's it gonna do hmm
well normally god it's so cute
yeah oh no it's got the graph oh my god
oh my god it's crisis people to death I
think oh my god okay so this is a boss
battle that's cool so we'll make sure
will you play this properly warning and
explained to Kay round about the king
round the importance of dodging it's
important to dodge but it didn't seem to
understand
oh well then oh god it actually crushes
people I don't know where I'm safe not
where the legs touch damn we did a lot
of damage shuffles furiously okay we're
gonna have to bow that's right
and you'll depend
it bowed back its crown loosen a little
hmm that's it Chris if we can get his
crown up it should turn back into a
little guy
Susie help us bow at it now it's crown
will come up when I smash this guide to
the ground
all right all right calm down Susie
please you could kill someone
[ __ ] in realize it was in the edge the
crown is 15% loose how convenient
number two no Act bow and now we have
some TP so we can heal an ally and will
heal Susie there you go so now we're at
30 I suppose oh my god he's got South
care what he's helping attack went up
Susie stop attacking it you're making it
stronger and I'll let it think I'm
afraid no way
the crowd is 30% loose okay so again
will bow and brows they will depend and
it bounced back the crown is ooh isn't a
little okay we should be at 45 Oh God I
don't know how I dodged that am I trying
to get killed
okay all right Chris as always well I'm
doing terribly but I think we're doing a
ride anyway I will have to heal Chris
this time so now we're at what Oh God
it's so sexy it's so distracting
sixty percent act foul defend I think
yeah we can defend one more time
seventy-five baby we can do this okay Oh
God
seventy-five seventy-five two more times
everybody all right so Chris will bow to
the king and you will hear shooting I
mean I should just let Susie dying
obviously sorry Susie
uh-oh
managed 90% loose okay I'm wonder there
could be a third act to be fair
act act double act Wow and magic to heal
Chris kawaii is it just rolling away you
won amazing we we did it
Wow you can't really our heroes
you saved the next twenty minutes of my
life yeah yeah I'm pretty great huh
I'm Suzy not to downplay your country
contribution but you you didn't actually
happen home to only made everything
worse by attacking it and if you had
just acted nice to it in the first place
we could have avoided that entire battle
huh are you for real
that thing was bloodthirsty the only
thing keeping it at my at bay was my ax
my ax and earlier you terrorized those
troops
those guys were enemies their fur tear
their [ __ ] her right yeah she's right
and before that you ate an innocent
persons cake putting it all on the table
cakes are also by enemy certain whatever
you like whether you like it or not
you're a hero one with the power to
bring peace to the future could you
please start acting like one
yeah when you lay it out like that I've
been a pretty bad here but have a night
all right
Rousey you've got it I'll change my
weight from now on I won't be such a
rotten hero anymore I'll just be one of
the bad guys who say none Annie
really you're going to be on my team
yeah sounds way easier honestly Suzy you
can't just quiet toothpaste boy Susan's
two-faced boy that's the best burn I've
ever heard in my life
Suzy is my car right now yeah two-piece
boy we're going to have a monogrammed
track jacket oh my god I want
monogrammed track jackets yeah
and sleepovers where we'll teach each
other secrets tell each other secrets
anyway see you guys never if you can
even last that long
Crais perhaps I shouldn't have been so
hard on her but I just worried that if
Suzy is too eager to fight then well
let's just be kind to her okay Chris I'm
sure Suzy will come around soon
this game is so funny I cannot I can't
remember the last time I place there's a
funny game it's so silly and I feel so
silly playing it it's great the blocky
foliage grows thick above your head the
power of the forest shines within you
saved all right see you guys again again
we managed to fix up this old thing
imagine for you it's some kind of dough
it can take you anywhere you want in the
world as long as that's one of two
locations anywho we'll keep working on
it any anything you to help you out kid
anywhere in the world huh whoa there
horsey mr. society and the puzzle guide
fixed at all since it was just there
three of us since it was just the three
of us it should work without any issues
anyhow haha hope it it helps deal with
the King Jesus Christ it's a door where
would you go feel their forest oh god I
wasn't ready to pick fields might be
nice the door open okay so did we go
back now we did okay so it's we can go
back to the shop that's cool
maybe we should buy something I don't
think we'd really need anything right
now maybe just for the sake of it I'll
buy a darker but I don't know I feel
like we should save the money because we
already have items oh so this is the
door that was empty before of course so
now we're in the forest oh alright well
that was simpler ah what in the world is
that Radek
what
it slithered in the way okay good now I
don't have to keep [ __ ] blow on it
why slithered in the way all right we'll
just do you think I can spray right away
oh it's so cute
oh we spared it okay we're back here
Susie nan say
well if it isn't their so-called heroes
are you finally ready to see what
happens when you try to act soft against
a team that crushes anyone in their way
dark Jack Lanza violent acts
zhuzi together we are this is Team
Rocket reference the dark the dark
squad so what's your evil plan dude
we're just form a team we haven't got
done any big pass or intro yet have a
little paste shin please oh I'm sorry
we're I'm looking for forward to the
rest
Hey well you won't have to look forward
for lo starting now we're going to work
ceaselessly unstoppably to make an ever
plan to thrash you clamps watch your
backs
and your France they didn't think about
our sides today I know they're playing
now God what are they good Jesus
all right so a soft and clean boy okay
doing grain love the colors in this game
very pretty it looks like we'd pick the
right turn what is this it's a stump
with some kind of dinner hole in it how
to evil scheming going Oh dad we got
bored so we're having a snake
I see come on I ate all I ate for
breakfast was chalk and I didn't need
anything sorry
what are you two having exactly just a
daily treasure I hid in this stem
orifice and that is feast for yourself
my main man Chris do you want to try it
browser you try it oh there's a honey
pot inside it's full of salsa
bingo you sweet little pumpkin it's my
secret stash a little snackaroo from me
to you mmm yummy it's delicious
come on you're just pretending to eat it
haha yeah that's what I do too
well guys everybody had enough
constantly Oh a gteen answer okay got a
washout don't want to get thrashed we'll
have a oka don't get thrashed now you
could get rashes hey a chest you open
the treasure inside was rag er you put
Ragnar in your weapons or is it a rag
girl or something you guys will call me
out on next episode I'm just a little
ball I don't want to discuss anything
hashtag relatable ah that scarf I
noticed that you simply took it without
asking that's fine it's my gift to help
you defeat the king you folks are really
energetic haha and potentially criminals
do you want the scarf back shoot with
the scarf back alright let's round sang
should put on their new scarf right but
it only increases attack and whatever
thanks for the scarf buddy oh that was
close
goddamn I love this game so fun to play
okay let's see here oh it's a puzzle
enter the password note due to everyone
forgetting the password it's hitting
haha great
should we talk to these guys just first
then add a mustache of the day okay
like this haha yeah that's perfect
how's the scheming coming along YouTube
hey don't looks spoilers dude alright I
don't wanna well well well look who it
is
the sweet little piece we love to seize
hey watch your language oh sorry
shoes is trying to get me to swear more
[Applause]
all right what happens then
wait so this one transformed into this
one and this one transformed into this
one okay so I start with this and then
okay
hey thanks for doing the puzzle for us
losers ha ha thank you so much losers we
were having trouble who we are Nita snip
what is this game it's so weird
Who am I fighting against it's like
you're playing and playing with a child
okay is it the same okay the puzzle all
right so one of those
[Music]
quite aside we can't reach in okay and
clever is that what it's called clover I
don't actually don't know and then do we
know the last one
Oh God Alison our cake came by what a
hunk he vandalized the parcel to stop
the Leitner's but we know the answers
oh you want to get through of course
we'll tell you the first symbol is hard
haha just like love does that help this
is another a simple puzzle all the
symbols are different I think you can
still see the colors they were too sorry
I can't be any more help so these are
the colors uh-huh and then simple puzzle
why should we care none of the symbols
are clubs okay do we have any other
clues
[Music]
but there's two of them
what's clubs okay so clubs is that
symbol there and one that were left one
is a hard so we shouldn't know it then
it should be
bamm-bamm
no that doesn't work it should be BAM
and then BAM and then the last one I
guess I don't know so but the colors are
the same so it must be this one okay we
did it guys
excellent oh my god hey it's my birthday
today and you didn't even say hello
that's fine actually stop and say hi
folks
shut up they don't deserve us hey calm
down YouTube
let's celebrate my birthday YAG and get
ready to hurt oh I'm sorry about this
personality kiss blade cat okay and
Hydra thing alright well do talk
birthdays talk sports talk boys let's
talk boys um what kind of boys do you
like
cute ones none I mean all nice ones like
I F
seems like Laura enjoy talking about
them glasses are cute I think fluffing
collapses that's it
oh wow they split okay talk about sports
do you guys like sports sports my
favorite food simply enjoy talking about
that spaghetti and tennis balls that's
genius
so random
is whispering about cute boys he's tired
of discussing so much if so we can spare
pacifier
all right if they're tired you pacify I
forgot all right we did it
let's do a save there in the heart of
the woods a bake sale stands quietly the
power of reoccuring bake sales shines
within you that is the strong power to
have interested in a cocoa diamond all
proceeds go to Rudin's relief funds I
guess okay it's only portaging sir
Thanks I guess the cocoa diamond was
added to your items okay what are you
Selden sorry I didn't read that honey I
was a hard donate proceeds who had these
help nah screw it help
all right what are you guys sir
greetings gentle clowns
may we interest you in a lancer cookie
all proceedings go to kicking your race
it's a mere 240g
hey dumbest it's for a good cause let's
just buy one Chris huh okay hey thanks
the Lancer cookie was added to your
items for getting cheated by us now we
may find her illicit plants I can't read
okay let's keep going here we are all
right
oh it saw me okay so apparently I can
miss these
Oh
Pressey to choose legs oh sorry see to
choose he's still unhappy oh I thought I
had to mess him up okay my bed okay
that's funny
Oh God it's Tetris all right God okay so
let's try that again
[Music]
all right so
oh I pick when I want I see there we go
and there we go oh he's pleased with its
new sound oh god I'm gonna knock your
block up alright let's rearrange this
guy so he can live a happy life there
you go
be free mr. box that was great all right
that's it
before the king came along I used to eat
the leaves from this tree now I still do
that such is the way of the worm the way
of the worm everybody it's the way of
life oh my god are you still in the
video I hope you're enjoying comments
way of the world it's the way I want to
live
thank you pretty bad for changing my
life and also you are the best youtuber
I hope t-series will become a worm
thanks very much
that was in you opened the treasure
chest
inside was revived mint my favorite you
put revived mint okay so I guess that
means I can drive a character the game
is pretty easy though to be fair maybe
there's a difficulty spike later cuz I
remember our detail is very challenging
some bosses at least towards the end
oho but I mean we're just starting as
well so woe is me rows and rows of words
and words if only a hero could help
Lancer is everything all right
I'm not Lancer I'm just a sweet little
boy why does a sweet little boy have a
moustache as a disguise so what kind of
help do you need see I have this evil
plan that I need to make and why does a
sweet boy need an evil plan to impress
his cool friend Suzie Chris if it's for
friendship
well then we'll gladly help what should
we do it's all on the paper you
delicious little apple okay let's see
here what does it say just fill in with
the most evil thing you can imagine
hahaha let the clown generated content
begin create a machine to trash your own
ass presented by Lancer Industries great
I guess he has his machines
the head should not be a duck oh my god
oh that's great
[Music]
kawaii
I end that's my machine Wow looks nasty
are you sure you aren't evil no I
suppose we just have an accurate Jesus
ha ha
tricked you idiots I shouldn't see that
coming never do something else never do
someone never do someone never do
something someone else can do for you
[Music]
it's even kind of high-class looking
anyway great job Lansing they were
sitting ducks
Murli ha ha yes and it's all thanks to
our enemies thank you very much thrash
you later
thrice you later everyone ok ok I hope
that ducks come in later
it's nice Susan you'd finally find a
place she fits in and she's getting
along with master - this is so sweet
what in the world God all right we run
towards a we're saying no that's not
true
but I manage somehow
anyway revolve around the center and
look carefully the darker gets the more
you can see not sure what that means
Oh God
[Music]
I made a terrible mistake I just have to
keep going into the dark
well now it's very dark so now we can
see more our God but only in here
[Music]
all right sue me something has changed
over here now might look like you can
walk around it but that's definitely not
the case
haha we see that thing over there huh
though hard to see there was a switch on
the tree okay I don't know what a tree
switch looks like but I don't want to
know as actually same station what in
the world is this how's the Thresh
machine we designed going the wat
machine the machine we had a whole
sequence about it yeah where is it
oh that yeah we'll make it it at the
last minute you two should really start
working on it earlier watch with a
lecture I didn't come here for a second
dad hey hey yeah you Dylan oh my god
somehow Prince Lancers made real friends
with a Lightner somebody should tell the
King immediately but it's definitely not
going to be me however whoever breaks
the news is gonna be rich by the way
beware yourself of the forest mace
you'll probably get completely lost
without someone who knows the way
through that is yeah I know there forage
like the back of my head oh there he is
okay so he went this way
[Music]
great
he's like so which way are we going now
we were following you
oh why I have no idea what I'm going
grace let's just go wherever Lancer
doesn't go great how did he end up here
okay Suz is in a loser wait a sec
where's Larsen well he wasn't going the
right way so you let him wander up by
himself you know he's been in meets us
right he's probably lost to confuse
right now hahaha I'm lost and confused
sorry Susie we didn't mean to make you
worry about him huh look I'm not worried
about bad guys got to look out for each
other they talk anyway get out of my way
I'm gonna fight it seems like she
doesn't know the right way either Chris
should we go back and get him
[Music]
okay but now oh we made it
after mace again cool oh oh it's boss
fight it's duck race isn't that the
machine we did redesigned all right this
will be tough but let's try our best to
now oh that's not good actually
[Music]
haha
you think that's bad just wait and see
what happens when it start your design
sex oh we blew with it ah I see so now
what's your plan going to be turns out
we didn't need a plane just a broom
anyone that gets in our way
gets crushed into dust but Suzie you
need us to return home doesn't crushing
us seem a little counterproductive see
that's where you're wrong you see I know
I can't get back without you guys but
being a good guy really isn't master so
at that I'm a little way we can just
settle this Oh God if you can beat me
I'll go back to being a good guy but if
you lose you laugh you guys will have to
become bad guys with us and do whatever
we say ha ha ha our wish is your command
so what do you say
don't bother answer me we were just
gonna thrash you anyways so see ya oh
yeah oh yeah all right let's do anything
and let's defend
you try to convincing Susan not to fight
there was no a thing no way shut up and
fight Diane I don't think oh my god I
don't think convincing you told Riley to
compliment the enemies you two look like
a really great team
I am proud lance has started to become a
little convinced flattery won't work on
us oh it's working on me that's great
[Music]
okay so again
smells like teamwork
you told Riley the lodge asleep and best
Lantern Suzy you too if we don't stop
fighting then someone might get hurt
Lancer became more convinced it's
working that's the point
really that's bad
[Music]
I might have to use items this turn
actually [ __ ] okay I'll answer anything
you two if we stop fighting then I could
I could braid your hair lots of became
almost fully commits okay one more time
I mean know what all right final blow
kindness I think we should all just get
along
oh my god that's super effective that's
the best move of all the time but since
he blocked the sound waves before the
reaches is try convincing someone that
gear you score for the bad guys I'm
blissfully ignorant okay they're making
fun of you Wow I'm not gonna tolerate
this they're having an evil laugh cons
okay I guess we'll have to sing Oh Suzie
fell asleep okay perfect
and now we can do anything
[Music]
uh-oh
What's Wrong dude I accidentally started
like in the enemies now seeing them just
makes me feel round and soft bad
atmosphere for battle though well if you
don't want to fight there's no point
badges over okay that was great
well you didn't beat us because you were
kind of cheated butter ganging up on
Lancer with that kindness but if I have
to I guess I'll go back to your same but
don't expect me to do anything but by
alright Suzy's back on the team ever
well we're happy to have you back Suzie
yeah let's just hurry up and go home I'm
Suzy does this mean we earned a team
anymore I mean of course we're still a
team you can be part of that [ __ ] squad
Wow me in the priests wait if I hang out
with the good guys then can we still
have monogrammed track jackets yeah
Russell will make okay sure
oh my god that face that face of
nightmares Lancer joins the team Lancer
join that party that's great alright
save there I feel like that's a good
time to end this okay let's just end it
there hope you guys enjoyed this video
if you did so L will leave support I
always appreciate it thank you very much
and I'll see you in the next episode
goodbye